[Music]
in bed book news book the [ __ ]
dictionary why is the diction of your
bed have you try to read it it's not
entertaining at all submitted by do my
coffee the old man means [ __ ]
and Vietnamese I'm pretty close an
influencers cookbook was recalled by the
publisher after critics said the recipes
could be dangerous who is it oh well if
it's dangerous and food and influencer
is it the kitchen kitchen but their
recipes aren't Dean you're like all
vegan and yeah that's super vegan I
thought it was gonna be like razor
blades in your [ __ ] cake to
break out your friends oh there you go
oh they're just like you some other
[ __ ] carrots [ __ ] that it's really
funny actually I have all their
cookbooks I don't think you guys have
heard of this one why you don't think
I'm educated it's called Fox meets beer
I've heard of it yeah we have Fox meets
it's a cookbook it's not the channel
name see I know exactly how many
followers do they have 116,000 yeah the
dots on my check yeah did you guys watch
cooking swiss dog ooh
I think we should don't good it's a
Japanese lady and then she has a [ __ ]
dog I know that she that this dog would
just sit on the counter the whole time
she's cooking yeah oh so you're saying
cooking with dog but what the Japanese
accent yeah because that's how she would
say cookie we should dog good and it was
just me a dog the whole time just [ __ ]
it's just sitting doing nothing during
the whole session and then he died this
time until this door you know but she
could never cook the same ever again
without the thought and then it got
really sad cuz then people stopped
watching
cuz in the dog there this is just
cooking voice
that's yeah stuff than just [ __ ]
shoulder I know
oh that would have been dope yeah oh
that I mean creeper though it's it's all
they're losing views and it would look
the same if cuz he didn't do anything
yeah that's the world she [ __ ] up
there missed opportunity
alright so this cardboard cutout this
blogger hoodie was Joanna
quanis she lives in Minnesota with her
three kids in her in her home she's cute
she is cute why she gets she looks young
yeah well you could start kids people
grow up really fast everywhere else yes
true why is she collecting plants yeah
why she got poison ivy on her back
seasoning yes
so she blogs about her life living no
woods foraging for food cooking and
crafting how cool oh she got Forest
recipes oh so the camera is like going
to the wood ten acorns yeah yeah exactly
and that's actually one of the corns
weird you hear a guam's
Oh a corn chicken nuggets and chip yeah
so that she pee in a bucket some of her
recipes she suggests that her readers
can like forge their own food from the
forest that's pretty cool including wild
mushrooms
she's also city shaming too though cuz
I'm like I can't even go with the forest
and forage yes so her cookbook it's
called tells for my foragers kitchen is
what it looks like branding on a marble
countertop yeah so this is her cookbook
and then there were a lot of one-star
reviews on Amazon because haters some of
these people they realize that her
recipes can be very dangerous what were
they like my uncle ain't a [ __ ]
mushroom and died because if you don't a
trained eye to know which ones are
poisonous and which ones are edible
that's dangerous that's one of them the
other one is in one of her recipes the
dark chocolate dipped fungi recipe she
tells her readers to use two cups of in
season forged mushrooms and she suggests
from varieties and one of them is morel
mushrooms and so those are really
dangerous because a lot of there's these
other types of mushrooms or they're
called they call them fake morals and
that can lead to nausea vomiting
abdominal pain but they look like more
what she didn't say use fake morals no
she said usual but there's me that
looked exactly but she's telling them to
eat them raw which is super oh no no
because then they can be had her back
for a second okay yes is she saying to
just wash them place them in parchment
paper dip them in melted chocolate
sprinkle salt and rose petals oh the
fridge or freezer to cool but she's not
saying to cook them and you have to cook
these wild mushrooms you have to cook
the morals or just cook cook them in in
general just wild mushrooms should
always be cut I see chief squirrel stew
no it's with the acorn one oh hey wait
hey corn cereal find a wild dog get some
milk
let's make way so what's controversial
about acorns because of the way she says
acorns could be poisonous if you don't
cook a right I think you can eat acorns
like group of people mind blown yeah
huge yeah you gotta ground them up
Indians did it I mean this sorry the
first American we see them on the floor
when we see them on that means they're
dried up and they're dead well it
depends if if if you see it with the
shower without the show because there's
something inside there oh then you gotta
take the acorn nut and then you gotta
process it but there's a certain way to
eat it or process it or else it's
poisonous or sour and then saying that
in order to process it it's called
leaching where it removes this chemical
that's called tannin and ingesting tenon
that can give you a really terrible
taste and it also makes you sick and it
could upset your stomach and so Louise
and her cookbook apparently she's like
not specifying exactly how to prepare
like ignore the taste and just swallow
it
she's made up her own [ __ ] basically
that's one and another one is for her
Minnesota wild rice french toast recipe
it's all skipper's telling me she's
telling her readers to just soak the
rice but not to fully cook it and so
she's like a Rob person doesn't own a
stove she does everything is [ __ ]
just sulk and fries well I mean that
these are the ones that are specifically
drawing up these red flags to a point
where the publisher recalled the code
cuz they're like that's not right she's
making up her own [ __ ] hole she's like
damn it we got caught alright yeah
they're doing the repo they're offering
anyone who bought it a refund the chef
any dead carcass recipes like if he's
just happen to stumble across a dead
deer and then there's like flies and you
grab the love me or like a plant and
like natural not really meat Oh wild
vegan she she's not really about I want
to learn some foraging [ __ ] like if you
do I do too but just not from her live
in the mud huh he needs some skills I
want to learn like a wilderness survival
yeah they'll be kind of cool and then
they give you like a picture of don't
eat fake mushroom eat good mushroom and
then like how can you you know what can
you eat dude annuities so fun is a JK
version of survivor then well I got
Vegas
I'm badge de Blasio
I'm in Vegas Bellagio or maybe we'll go
to TI you know Vegas survivor is you
have no money and then how you gonna get
it we find the deals but the free rooms
girls don't work for the guy no you guys
just hang out at the other dicks
oh that's changed no girls happy girls
have two dresses yeah you have two
dresses guys and tape your boobs down
I'm down I know what did you forget my
so we wait till they work their magic
Damon no boobs you wear how you gonna
get my life I just got these people are
into it yeah damn but I have a plan my
plan is you wait with the girls right
when they work their magic they make
lots of money they need drug them and
then he's take the money
oh the biggest tactic that's because you
still keep looking I live in the sewers
in Vegas yeah I read about that that's
the way you can now I just saw the
headline literally like damn live on
take a news but we're just finding out
right now in this moment live long as
you read the Franklin you don't like her
no I like I like I like her you like her
she did yeah I used to always confused
her with Etta James all he had me too
she did a cover of that Beatle song
Eleanor Rigby and it was really dope we
could it took us a while to realize it
was a cover oh you thought it was
original
yeah well yeah because you can't even
tell it doesn't even go to the same tune
it's just the same lyrics yeah she's not
even of our time - I know she's like our
parents generation she's like a legend
legend 26 she died advanced pancreatic
cancer and neuro undercurrent and of the
neuro endocrine title Dan all right Pete
yeah that sucks
Austin and I wonder if she knew how to
eat which mushrooms it wouldn't be weird
if she was like she died from eating the
tannins from Halo shrooms oh man she
read about
but do you do do have friends that are
like super forager like the vegan before
gene friends oh absolute Anya is yeah
yeah I go my friend Tanya who was one of
my bridesmaids she is eating her front
lawn all the time she she knows how to
survive in the wilderness like she just
goes for weeks at a time like camping
herself yeah she wants to take us out
there and do allstate do that or no
mushroom what does she bring for food
mushrooms I know she hunts that's dope
what kind of huntin yeah like like with
a gun rabbit says I want to experiment
and see what happens to my body for like
a year of not eating processed food or
anything and just you could do that
without for it start in January what how
to do it in there like that I can't
that's boring why don't just compile
produce and then have you forage for it
- it's like it's like waking up Gary Oh
funny test would be like Joe goes to the
forest and then but before he gets there
like all of us spend 48 hours like
taping flamin hot cheetos - dude if we
and we can make a diet coke river it's
like a white-trash willy wonka yeah or
he thinks it's the diet coke grouper
because we told them there was one
that's really good its carbon you wanna
kill me it's all maker store I don't
John la
[Music]